hey what's up khan academy students it's  tony hawk i just want to wish you guys  the best i know it is the strangest of  times to be  in school feeling isolated and uh  just know we're going to get through  this and it's going to show  your determination your perseverance  making it through and  and doing well in school because it's  hard my daughter's in the same boat  and it's hard for her to stay motivated  but you can do it you just got to dig  deep  believe in yourself and i hope you guys  can can make it a great year in spite of  everything the world has thrown at you  alright and i'm pulling for you i'll see  you on the other side of this  okay thanks guys